jamais
mais sur une autre note acadienne la
chanteuse lisa leblanc s'est fait
connaître des francophones du pays par
ses textes c'est par sa personnalité
colorée l'an dernier à l'avancé un mini
album de chansons en anglais histoire de
tâter le marché anglophone
elle consacrera d'ailleurs les prochains
mois à l'écriture d'un nouvel album
sera-t-il en français en anglais ou
pourquoi pas en franglais maxence
bilodeau est allé à sa rencontre dans
l'ouest canadien
le sud albertain dans toute sa splendeur
la vie et cannes iriver treize mille
habitants au sud de calgary
mais parfois le vent se lève al'approche
d'une tornade lice alban
éclairage maison ambiance familiale le
spectacle est organisé par le festival
de fautes de l'emploi 10 ha de plans se
dit ravi par l'ambiance qui le soir
tombe sur hay river les spectateurs
arrivent
bonne nouvelle la salle est pleine de
malice et 3 6 2 de fringe bieber next de
bar une salle essentiellement anglophone
plutôt agi seul
pas de chansons traduites ses chansons
françaises dit sale blanc des chante en
français
si elle fait une tournée au canada
anglais c'est parce qu'elle a maintenant
en plus six chansons en anglais
match de ce trio est pas fou
on aurait pu penser le contraire mais ça
n'a pas été facile pour elle de d'écrire
en anglais
pour moi ça a été autant un challenge en
anglais parce que c'est encore plus de
recherches sont encore plus de deux
fouilles âge parce que c'est pas ma
langue maternelle c'est quelque chose
que j'ai parlé toute ma vie mais que tu
vas quand même être plus à l'aise je
pense en français quand même saut pour
move à l'anglais c'est vraiment comme
les dictionnaires tout le temps être des
titres de re re checker des affaires
tout en décriant en anglais ces textes
sont plus neutres moins typé camp
français où elle se distingue par
l'utilisation du joie les du chiac en
anglais c'est différent c'est comme
c'est en fait c'est du coup c'est très
très très fort que j'ai trouvé une toune
en anglais utilisant ça que je trouvais
qu'ils étaient complètement efficaces
mais je sais comme il est l'atout
n'aurait pas pu exister sans ce sérum
qui même souvent je suis même tourné of
pensent eux
questel leur chante
et pauvre albert terre vont bien de la
difficulté à reprendre en choeur cette
chanson
mais ils savent reconnaître la force du
rythme et se laisse emporter par la
tornade lisa leblanc
oui
quelle énergie dit ces fables oh mon
dieu
étape suivante
changement de décor calgary ville de
plus d'un million d'habitants
lisa leblanc joue dans la toute nouvelle
salle du festival de fourbe de calgary
c'est qu'il est francophone ici et là
ici beaucoup d'adeptes à qui elle
parlera en français en anglais en
franglais jackson et chantera toujours
avec cette même voix riche et distincte
cette donnée spectacle c'est sa dernière
après suivront de longs mois consacré
uniquement à l'écriture d'un nouvel
album
d'autant plus difficile à écrire que le
premier a connu tant de succès c'est
comme suit pas être sèche que m
et en quelle langue sera ce nouvel album
des sales blancs ne le sait pas encore
quelques chansons sont déjà écrites en
français et en anglais
il
je vais sûrement continuer j'écris dans
les deux sens j'aime les deux un autant
que les autres avec oui je continue à
chantons dans relève lui aussi chanteur
français pour trouver l'inspiration
issa leblanc doit faire ce qu'elle aime
c'est à dire prendre la route notamment
aller se balader aux etats unis 60 jours
allait faire ses roachs et pleure parce
que je vais jusqu'au maroc a fait du
mone j'entends des histoires passées
comme je were des scénarios viêt au
maroc ce qui vient d'arriver la com
en attendant place aux francophones de
calgary tous en choeur